hey you know people I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Rubin report I have two guys with
great names Alonso Darrell Dave max
Eluga veer award-winning names on the
show this week let's get right to it
Hillary Clinton have you heard about
this lady her husband was the former
governor of Arkansas he became president
then she became a senator from New York
then she became Secretary of State now
she wrote a book called hard choices and
she was interviewed by Diane Sawyer on
ABC News and had some interesting things
to say about the Clintons life post
presidency it has been reported you've
made five million making speeches the
president's made more than a hundred
million dollars well if you you have no
reason to remember but we came out of
the White House not only dead broke but
in debt we had no money when we got
there and we struggled to you know piece
together the resources for mortgages for
houses for Chelsea's education you know
it was not easy they had no money when
they got there I didn't know that and
then not only dead broke but in debt
when they left max we were watching this
before we started and you picked up on
an interesting added s I mean she makes
it sound like her life was really hard
having multiple houses yeah yeah it was
plural I can't believe that they left
the why is that true well actually
according to open secrets in 2000 when
the Clintons left the White House they
had a net worth of negative ten million
dollars but you could only get to a net
worth of negative ten million dollars if
you had access to tons of money before
that so for her to imply that somehow
they were dead broke or really in debt
knowing how much money was about to come
in 100 million bucks frankly there are
levels of insanely rich yeah okay and we
will probably never be in this boat but
I get where she's coming from you know
that's true it's all possible but no I
mean I mean I think yes I'm there's a
there's a little bit of disingenuous and
genuine is going on here but at the same
time yet they had to pay a lot of legal
fees for all that white
crap and all the other sort of [ __ ]
accusations that got hurled of them over
the course of eight years they had a
daughter to put through school yes they
have multiple houses I'm not no one is
thinking that these people are you know
gonna go on food stamps or understand
the idea of genuine poverty but I don't
begrudge them the ability to make money
making speeches I mean you know well
we'll get to that part I don't think
anyone progresses them the chance to
make money by the way Bill Clinton as
former president gets you know a yearly
salary the stipend of like 120,000 which
is still more than most people make on
top of all the money for speeches and
all that but that all right so let's
talk about then what happened after so
then Hillary chimed in with this first
of all we had to pay off all our debts
which was you know you had to make
double the money because of obviously
taxes and then pay off the debts and get
us houses and take care of family
members but do you think Americans gonna
understand five times the median income
in this country for one speech well let
me put it this way I thought making
speeches for money was a much better
thing than getting connected with any
one group or company as so many people
who leave public life do oh she's so
much better than everyone else in public
life because not there's not only this
she doesn't take money from one giant
company she takes money pretty much from
everybody she's taking a lot of money
from goldman sachs defend her go how
many seconds before Eric Cantor becomes
a lobbyist all right robbing door is for
these people to go back and like shill
for you know big armaments or for farm
or whoever else so I you know I will at
least give her the point like yeah you
expect you you accept money for speeches
you were at least singing for your
supper it's a great supper obviously but
you're not in anybody's pocket you know
with so many former politicians all
right look I'm so terrible think she's
in any one when she takes 500,000 for
two speeches to collapse another I'm not
saying the Clintons are pure and perfect
or anything else but I'm just saying I
think we're kind of piling on for a
relatively non gross way of being a
former politician you know what other
people are doing yeah yeah I've seen
Clinton speak on behalf of
Clinton Global Initiative and I you know
I'm always you know completely inspired
by by him and the work that they're
doing and yeah I don't begrudge them
anything yeah but this is to me this
isn't about begrudging because I agree
with you they have to make money somehow
people pay them for these speeches
that's fine I was you know we are a
capitalistic society it's more the idea
that she's framing it as if they
struggled which it's so do you think
they've ever not been able to get since
he's been president or even probably a
little bit before that do you think
there's anything they've ever wanted
that they haven't been able to get have
they ever not been able to go to a
restaurant that they wanted to go to or
buy a car that they wanted or or
anything so it's the struggle it's not
the right but maybe the question here is
why is Diane Sawyer framing it like oh
how dare you make this much money
go ask george w bush that question go
ask you know any former senator who is
now you know Schilling from
northrup-grumman that question water to
why when Hillary it's like when Hillary
does it suddenly it's the worst thing
ever
well I totally hear that and listen I
would give Dick Cheney as much [ __ ] for
you know helping Halliburton get
contracts would you end up back so yeah
I'm just giving them all equal this
isn't necessarily all about reminds me
of that line from The Dark Knight Rises
we're talking about superhero movies so
it brings it I mean they don't even go
broke like the rest of us none of us
could I ever get in ten million dollars
that that would be virtually impossible
this is this is a one-percent style
bankruptcy yeah which is there somebody
is willing to loan you ten million and
you're able to pay it back and then some
yeah a pretty good set of problems why
is it that people are so afraid of being
proud of success because I think that
that goes to what you're saying about
Diane Sawyer's question there's this
this idea that everyone has to be
struggling all the time people who are
running for president need to come off
as relatable and you know I you know I
hear vague things I don't know but you
know I think she this is clearly part of
the narrative of you know just plain
folks which they have worked to a
certain extent or other ever since
leaving Arkansas yeah do we do you think
we have this like weird implicit shame
about success in this country um you
know if we do it's sad you know I like
to think that we should you know be
proud of people and hold people as
examples when they become successful for
no
will causes you know and I think it's
important to see them as relatable but I
think that their their necessity for
that has passed you know that's what got
him into office yeah well yeah I mean I
you know again I think that that the
success that they've had post post
presidency I think is warranted yeah all
right well I think what we learned here
is that I will not be voting for Hillary
I think Alonzo will be voting for
Hillary I will maybe I don't know who
runs against runner and Max possibly I
see a possible I see a probable okay all
right let's move on a computer by the
name of Eugene because what other name
would a computer have passed the Turing
test which basically means it simulated
humored human conversation as a
thirteen-year-old boy we've got a little
more info for you the Turing test which
tests artificial intelligence was
introduced by Alan Turing in 1950 he
predicted that computers would one day
be able to be programmed to acquire
abilities rivaling human intelligence
we're pretty much right there a person
engages in a text-based conversation
with another person and a computer and
must determine which is which if they're
unable to do so the computer is deemed
to have passed it requires 30 percent of
human interrogators to be duped during
five-minute keyboard conversations so I
feel like we've all before we get into
the specifics of this feel like we've
all had these experiences with these
computers like if you go on to like Time
Warner chat to try to find something out
and you literally can't tell if you're
talking to so does this surprise you
that this test has been paid what I have
been reading what I've been reading
about this online is that if this is a
hoax that this guy okay no yeah this guy
at Reading University is apparently
infamous for these sort of things I
think he claimed to be the first human
to be infected with a computer virus and
that apparently a lot of people have
been sort of gullibly kind of reporting
this story but it's not true so it
seemed it seems like it's half true that
apparently this did it did actually pass
but there's some questions about his
methodology so I don't want to get too
focused on that just more the broad sort
of broader idea by the way real quick
about Alan Turing he was persecuted for
homosexuality and after he was convicted
in 1952 he was chemically
castrated a little something there and
after winning World War two thanks very
much yeah no no he's one of the great
game Arturs of history and actually
doesn't be a movie about him starring
Benedict Cumberbatch coming out this
year really so hopefully at that and I
think a stamp will get him his do I
think but ya know Alan Turing is a what
is it you're really smart gay people
because the guy from a beautiful mind
also although the movie made it seem
like it wasn't he gay uh yeah weird you
know smart gay guys are good with
numbers I don't alright so going back to
this without getting too much into the
to the specifics of the test cuz it's a
little unclear as yet when are the
robots taking over as I somehow asked on
this show every week what's interesting
is that Ray Kurzweil particularly this
would happen by 2029 is obviously a lot
sooner than that but I think that well
no I mean you know you met Chris well
that like the fifties guy you know from
outer space the old TV psychic ok never
my thing we need to redefine how we how
we define artificial intelligence you
know I mean obviously this is a test
that was devised in 1950 so a lot of
those ideas you know whenever they tried
to predict the future in the 50s it ends
up looking ludicrous but um well yeah
but uh you know I think it's um what's
interesting is that this device what
they told the the jury panel that it was
a 13 year old boy in English was not his
first language automatic cranium is
great yeah and and so I don't think it's
a surprise that that he won you know and
but it was hardly a supercomputer was an
algorithm that was designed to be
chatbot and by the way this isn't even
the first time that that happened robot
in 2011 called the cleverbot that did
this in india
so again when do the robots take over I
wanted I want a date I think it's
neck-and-neck do the robots take over
before or after we render the earth
uninhabitable to human action you're
going to be a great time yeah that's I
think you know to who's gonna get there
first I don't know yeah do you guys
think that maybe some of this like I
always talk about it as if the robots
are a takeover we do thing on Google
cars last week they won't even have
steering
wheels so you'll be trapped in your cars
two people we were to hack into them and
then we're all walking around with these
devices so they can watch us and listen
to it's about am I just totally alarmist
on this and that being said I still do
all this stuff and I love it I think
it's so cool and I love all the movies
about it but is that just purely
alarmist I think I think it's great I
think the idea of having driverless cars
could potentially save us from having
lots of accidents I mean there was a
huge accident in the news over the
weekend about a truck driver who hadn't
slept for 24 hours and caused that huge
pileup and then Tracy Morgan right you
know Google is now they're offering like
you know cloud storage for autism
research which is supposed to be amazing
so I'm definitely like bullish on the
future I think that like technology has
amazing things to offer and you know
it's it's it just gets sort of out of
hand when the media takes something
that's not really a story and you know
blows it out of proportion the way they
did with this supercomputer but I do
think that at the end of the day we're
heading in the right direction yeah you
know III wish Google would stop
censoring the Chinese internet but they
are obviously maybe making a lot of cool
things happen and I'm not I don't worry
so much about what we're what we're
surrendering the technology as much as
I'm not kidding I really wonder if if if
Skynet is gonna take over if they're
gonna beat us to destroying the ozone
layer and you know like making them all
the ice caps melt right or as in what
happens in the Terminator movies and
like wall-e that they'll have to enslave
us because we're the ones that are
destroying the earth and it'll be
against their written orders their laws
and then they'll have to turn on us I
for one welcome our new robot overlords
there you go all right let's move on
this is wild a company out of Oklahoma
is producing for $1000 bulletproof
blankets for kids to use in schools
because of this is the same amount of
school shootings of course we had
another one yesterday it just never
stopped there was a one the week before
we've got some images of the blankets so
yeah a thousand bucks it can protect
against 90% of the weapons that have
been used in school shootings in the
United States there were 13 school
shootings in the US the first six weeks
of 2014
we're now four months past that so I
guess first is this just inevitable that
every kid is gonna be going to school
with a bulletproof blanket I don't even
have words for how appalling the idea
that we now have to kevlar our kids
blankets in schools because god forbid
we do any tiny tiny thing about guns in
this country and said no we all have to
walk around with bulletproof vests
that's the answer I'm I can't even I
mean I definitely think they're a good
idea you know I mean they they're
attempting to solve there's something to
put out the smoke rather than put out
the fire right now for lack of a better
expression but because it doesn't look
like gun reform is happening anytime
soon in this country and people were
actually dying you know I mean there was
just another shooting that occurred you
know yesterday I think that to have
those in schools would be a positive
thing and the end the bulletproof doors
that they've been experimenting isn't it
all a little bit of sort of fake
protection because the idea that the kid
would be you know when this would happen
I assume they don't keep them on them
all the time or probably you've been
under their desks that you know uni and
by the time you were able to get it out
of the closet or something the bad stuff
is already happen so a lot of this is
just sort of just I don't know is it
fakery for the parents mind telling kids
oh by the way you could get shot at any
moment so do keep this handy ya know so
that's the part that I think the most
interesting do you think that we that
the real bad part is is the conditioning
that all these kids are gonna grow up
thinking that this is just really part
of the way life is even though I guess
it is at some level but I think that you
have to adapt to the times like I went
to high school or I should say
elementary school in Manhattan and we I
remember growing up we had drills where
we would have to get out of the desks in
case there was a like a nuclear attack
or something like that
I remember there was you have to get
under the desks and brace yourself for
some kind of like attack or something
like that
yeah yeah and this was like in New York
and obviously I don't think that that
applies today but today we have this
very real and present you know danger of
school shootings inside something I read
online this week that I thought was
interesting was that one of the great
semantic sort of you know twists of
recent years is that we keep calling
these Shu
and nobody ever calls them murders and
that if we called them murderers maybe
we would take them more seriously but
shootings just sort of seems more
innocuous and that and that's allowed us
to kind of process this in a daily basis
that it's constantly happening and we
aren't more appalled by them yeah is
that the other scary part here is that
so when I saw the shooting yesterday I
don't even remember where it was where
was it cuz this happens constantly right
it was in Oregon and I guess the shooter
and one other guy in North Hollywood a
couple days ago right and then what was
the one last week last week was in Santa
Barbara right or was that a week and a
half ago but I think it's happening and
this goes to the conditioning part is
when I see on Twitter there's a shooting
now it doesn't even faze me for a split
second or you know what I mean I'm like
oh another one like and that to me is
the scary part so are we just becoming
someone oh yeah I mean are we just
becoming more and more okay with this so
I so this is something these blankets
even if it's not real protection
I thought your flanks are completely
exposed on those things like you need a
dome at least for something like a big
turtle show you should get into that I
mean if they save one life you know it's
a great initiative yeah so if we can't
change the gun laws which it seems like
we can't seem to do since we couldn't
get anything passed after Newtown and
Sandy Hook if we can't do that then what
what should we be tackling should we
attack in mental health more because it
seems to me there's a lot a lot to do
with mental health and prescription
drugs yes sir there's mentally he'll
mentally ill people all over the world
and there are violent videogames all
over the world and there are frustrated
single guys all over the world this is
the country where all those people get
guns exactly yes and if video games
cause violence as I say every time I'd
be an Italian plumber eating mushrooms
jumping on Turtles and I am eating
mushrooms but that is nothing to do with
the video game okay let's move on is the
American Dream crumbling a new poll says
that nearly six out of ten people say
that the American Dream is now
impossible to achieve in this country
this is a poll from CNN money's American
Dream poll conducted by o RC
International
so young adults aged 18 to 34 well I'm
not even in that group anymore that is
said are most likely to feel the dream
is unattainable with 63% saying it's
impossible that is incredibly depressing
63% of all Americans said most children
in the US won't be better off than their
parents and 67% of Americans say they
have not achieved the American dream I
remember when I was in tenth grade or
eleventh grade I took a class I think it
was like a social studies like an
offshoot social studies class and the
teachers saying that you guys are gonna
be the first generation that in America
that's gonna be worse off than their
parents and I remember like that like
hit me like oh [ __ ] like this and now
it's active that was 20 years ago and
now it's actually happening how
disturbing is this I mean as a member of
the generation that they were I think I
think the idea of the American dream has
definitely evolved you know and I think
it's a lot different for young people
today you know I say if anything we are
the access generation access means more
to us and I think it should then
ownership Kevin Kelley is a phenomenal
author he talks a lot about you know
technology and futurism stuff says that
access is better than ownership and I
believe that you know we live in the age
of uber you know it's you can Obert
today with greater ease than it is
owning a freaking car you can Airbnb you
know places all around the world rather
than owning a house and I think that
some it's just a different world we live
in you know like it's better to have
access to things than to own stuff and
and so I'm perfectly okay with that
you know Wow a little a little hope off
a depressing study what do you think I
mean obviously the American Dream is
sort of vague and amorphous and and you
know it is what you think it is but as
far as the idea of people not thinking
that they aren't going to do better than
their parents I mean that is sadly the
reality and I think that all kind of
stems from everything since Ronald
Reagan basically has been about the
dismantling of the 20th century the
dismantling of you know labor unions the
dismantling of voting rights the
dismantling of everything that was
making us a more perfect union and that
was providing education for people and
and you know the the the
was the country that that you know went
to the moon all the stuff that we
accomplished when we got past the Gilded
Age we're now back to the Gilded Age
we're now back to the you know the point
one percent and then the rest of us and
I think and and and as you said the
point one percent by the way cuz it's
not the one person we've talked about
many times the one percent makes
somewhere around $400,000 which
obviously is great I don't make anywhere
near that but those aren't the people
that are really in that top echelon the
tiny amount of people who control the
massive amounts of wealth the tax breaks
they have been given by taking their
money offshore by taking jobs offshore
by not reinvesting in their companies
you know and instead just hoarding it
off somewhere that is this is the Reagan
effect this is the country we live in
now this is the country where where was
was once the land of opportunity and is
now not so much
I like this we had hope and now we have
no hope we should you know every
generation should reassess what it means
to do good you know like are we happier
what the three is sure are we safer you
know are we do we fuel you know more
sort of creatively expressed you so that
though then seems like the scary part to
me because if 63 percent are saying that
that dream is impossible even though the
Hopi parts that you gave which are
pretty good even though those exist
these people still don't think that
whatever the idea of the dream is of
happiness that's the part I think is
interesting here maybe happinesses is
unattainable I don't know if that study
is is you know questioned you know
Millennials whether or not they thought
that I'm right you believe that the
dream is impossible whatever you think
the dream is if you're saying it's
impossible it seems like it might affect
your happiness right yeah I know it
wasn't an index is a subjective thing
the dream I guess yeah I don't know I
think that we have the tools to be
happier than our parents you know or
maybe not honestly no no I mean I I
think you're right a lot of it's very
subjective I don't think you know if the
American Dream used to be about I don't
know owning a home in the suburbs
clearly that's not as much of the goal
anymore
and and I you know I agree with you that
we were moving away from the sort of
idea of you know that it was about
possessions or about you know these sort
of uh you know marks lines in the sand
you
to to be a successor to achieve the
dream but as far as just the basic of
you know my parents were immigrants to
this country and they wanted their kids
have more opportunities they would have
had if they'd stayed in Spain and I
think that parents want their kids to do
better and now we're looking at kids
realizing that's not gonna happen and
that's kind of demoralizing yeah that is
a scary thought I want to spin this
positively before we go max give me one
final thought that's gonna make everyone
feel really good about the futures in my
Rubert
say a couple buzzwords oculus rift so
you can live in a virtual yeah in a
virtual happy world okay very good
let's move on so I saw this commercial
online this is a YouTube only commercial
or advertisement or promo that coca-cola
did sort of explaining how you would
burn off calories by drinking one can of
their delicious soda let's take a look
okay so we actually splice that so you
didn't get the full thing there but the
whole thing is on YouTube but basically
they're trying to make it seem like it's
this fun cool thing having to burn off
the calories that it takes 23 minutes of
exercise if you're 140 pounds for one
little 12 ounce can of coke
there's something very perverse about
this is it reminds you remember that a
certain I live ad for pork and it was it
was all people exercising and really
working hard like I do all this so that
I can eat pork exactly except it's
really exactly the parody has now become
the real thing and and the this ad is so
well first of all Danny Elfman should
sue for the slight tweak the pee-wee's
big adventure theme yeah but also the
idea that you know yes you can if you
bike for 20 minutes you're at you're
entitled to a coke despite the fact that
a coke has more sugar than the ED and
the average adult should consume in the
entire day it's poison yeah I mean that
[ __ ] is you know and of course it's high
fructose corn syrup we don't even get
the actual sugar you have to go to
Mexico right and even though you're
starting to go high fructose the whole
calorie thing being the end all and be
all is I think pretty much been
establishes kind of a myth of dieting
not that I clearly I'm a weight loss but
you know I think that that's very much
oversimplifying the thing and so this ad
kind of brings up like I just you know
get out of workout and then you get to
slug down our sugar we get too too deep
into the calorie part I mean doesn't the
idea of what they're doing here seem
really twist I mean the marketing
tactics that these you know junk food
companies you know used to me is
completely pervasive and it drives me
crazy I mean did you guys read that
study that came out last week about how
diet soda you know helps people lose
weight which was actually a study funded
by the American beverage it's crazy
because most studies say that it
actually makes you crave sugar and that
you know of course it converts into
benzene your body and go to McDonald's
can order a ton of awful food and then
they get a diet soda I think never
offsetting it yeah yeah anybody who's
interested in this topic should see my
friend Lori David's movie fed up it's a
documentary in theatres now it's all
about this how it's not just you know a
calorie and versus a calorie on how
these you know by drinking a can of soda
it actually spikes your insulin it
prevents you from feeling satiated you
know so it makes you hungrier
and it's a it's a major player in the
obesity epidemic let's cook even Coca
Cola's water brand Dasani has salt in it
yes it's on the label its salt is in
that [ __ ] so you guys stay thirsty it's
insane
okay so then what is coke doing here
what are what are they really what are
the marketing people saying like they're
just saying we know that people are more
health conscious so we're gonna make it
seem fun no you know no one's using this
actual machine for exercise I do cardio
not fun and actually it's sport now that
I've been doing it more it's forced me
to cut some of this stuff out of my diet
if they had that Rube Goldberg thing at
a gym I might consider going to one you
know there's a big giant hand gonna give
me a coke at the end I might you know I
want that full pee-wee Herman thing
where you do that whole thing just to
get the milk in your cereal absolutely
you know what's that cocaine rolls down
all those things gonna be in your face
when you open it though problem that is
a good point
I guess eternal position coke is like a
reward like there's no better reward for
exercise you know for then a coke that
kind of coke right there's no better
reward for exercise than doing something
that reverses all the does not quench
your thirst at all after the exertion
you've just gone through it haven't
brought two teas
yeah by the way a little more info on
the average soda drinker consumes about
two point six glasses each day so if
this was two point six cans of coke that
would mean about an hour of cycling so
this stuff is just not good for you and
but when we do all these stories
everyone then attacks me and says you
know we should have our indulgences and
that kind of thing yes I drink some of
this stuff too
but we should be more aware of what's
going on here right it's so sometimes
food as they say on Sesame Street you
know it's a sometimes food you know if
you have like a coke every couple of
weeks you know it's not gonna be the
worst thing in the world for you but
yeah 2.6 a day that's insane yeah so
final thought on this should we give
coke any credit then just trying to play
devil's yeah Dasani is the least
offensive product that they market but
even that's tap water and we're
overpaying for it so yeah final topic
half of Americans believe in conspiracy
theories I love this story Rhys
the studies suggest that around 50% of
Americans subscribe to at least one
conspiracy theory this info is coming
from NPR social science car spotted
shankar Venn dan tam did I pronounce
that right you guys are definitely NPR
people no I think I think I was closed
from NPR's Morning Edition let's look at
the findings of a study so 19 percent of
Americans believe the US government was
behind the 9/11 attacks that seems
incredibly high to me so we'll get back
to that in a sec 25 percent believe the
recent financial crisis was caused by a
small cabal of Wall Street bankers and
here's a good one 11 percent believe the
government is mandating a switch to
compact fluorescent light bulbs because
the light bulbs make people obedient and
easy to control now I will play the
rational person here for one second Carl
Sagan said that extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence that's
generally how I think about these things
although I put the I have no problem
with aliens I'm pretty sure aliens have
been here and are manipulating us the
19% on 9/11 seems really high to me what
do you think although I know about
YouTube commenters that's probably very
low I mean yeah I do I believe in that
number or do I think that it just seemed
high that one out of five Americans
would would believe that it was like
when you think about it rationally but
it actually seems low and you think that
you know in a moment of sheer panic and
helplessness you know in times like that
the part of our brain the amygdala
that's the fear center goes into or it
sends our brain into analytical
overdrive and it leads to us sort of
coming up with these narratives that
help us better explain these
circumstances which is is so out of the
ordinary and so you know so fearful and
yeah in a way in a country where this
many people believe what they hear on
Fox News nothing surprises me frankly so
I mean think about conspiracy theories
is that you know it's not like the
government is so pure that we can't ever
believe that any of them you know they
we didn't put smallpox in blankets and
give it to the Native Americans I mean
it's not like we're the US government is
incapable of shenanigans so it's not the
hardest thing to believe that
shenanigans are happening you know
let me call it shenanigans I mean we do
subsidize a lot of the products that are
making people you know obese in this
country and so you know it's corn corn
corn why the government once makes it is
making it difficult for you know Tesla
to sell cars because the oil companies
are paying them to do it you know so why
not then think that maybe the CIA
decided to kill John F Kennedy or
something I mean you know okay so let's
talk about the fluorescent light bulb
then because I think that one's amazing
so eleven percent are saying that these
new government mandated light bulbs the
light is actually a way of controlling
you what do you think fluorescent lights
of my high school and nobody was being
controlled so I'm not buying that one
not that that to me seems like a
fluoride in the water a kind of right
you know john birch sort of wackiness i
don't know do you research on the
fluorescent I don't know I mean I can
only you know tell you know of my
personal experience under fluorescent
lights I've always felt like a little
more anxious really yeah really
yeah they look weird they're not
flattering those fluorescents Oh
interesting
so by feel weird what do you mean by
that well I just you know it's it's the
lighting is never good it's never you
know comfortable you know as a kid I
never really liked being under that sort
of false life there's also an audible
component to it fluorescent lights and I
don't yeah I have like a home that I
think sets people off it's like tape
hiss almost you know it's got this like
really sort of you know subtle effect
and your subconscious but I don't know I
mean it's it's a pretty crazy idea that
the government will be trying to is that
the beauty of conspiracy theories you
don't have to prove any of them so it's
like yeah it's what's fun to believe in
something stuff like the alien stuff
obviously I have no proof but it also it
also feels good to think that you're you
know in a pack of sheep that you're the
wolf that has the idea you're not being
fooled yeah do you guys have one that
you subscribe to I guess maybe the JFK
anything for you know the CIA I I feel
like there's more to the JFK thing than
we're being told but I don't know what
it is I haven't done the research listen
I saw the Oliver Stone movie many times
I dig it
down what do you think I'm not into
conspiracy theories nah not really not
my thing
nothing no all right but we know for a
fact that Bush wanted to invade Iraq the
second he entered office and that's
actually like that's not that's not even
consider that's a thing that we know now
so that's well that's the kind of thing
that makes conspiracy theories
believable look at us ending a
conspiracy theory segment with a fact
that is some of it alonzo max thank you
guys their Twitter's are right down
below check them out doing all the crazy
stuff that they're doing you're working
on new a brain thing we're gonna really
thing yeah I can't say much about it but
yeah it's gonna be cool but the brain
man that's out there I mean sorry thanks
thanks for watching guys we'll see you
next time